I've heard Annabelle sentiment when I
was in stockholm in two years ago they
were told still trying to decide on the
design and I saw the various models and
I really like the one they chose so I
was very happy to see a chosen I think
it's a great idea I think that you know
everyone often think that the Nobel
foundation is about the Nobel Prize
that's just a very small part of the
activity the museum will be wonderful
having a extra beautiful sights before
the building will be fantastics I'm a
real fan of the new building I think it
should be used for all the types of
functions and I think these functions
are going to change you know maybe small
dialogues I think that increasing in the
world one has internet learning for
large things with in small groups to
discuss things that then get broadcast a
bit like we're seeing here and I think
that's fine i'm sure they would be very
innovative you know it's great to see an
organization that is more than 100 years
old being really cool about Twitter and
other things and that's just what we
want